Donald Trump's been waging a battle
against alternative energy and against
logic and against reason and he's now
claiming that the noise that wind
turbines make causes cancer which is of
course not true on the basis of anything
that's known to the species Homo sapiens
at this point in time you might remember
that trumps had a long list of bogus
critiques of wind power he recently said
you don't want to rely on wind power
because wind sometimes doesn't blow he's
talked about wind power killing birds
which it does that's true but it kills
them at a lower rate than other energy
sources so recently Trump spoke to
Republicans and he said they say the
noise from wind turbines causes cancer
this is extraordinarily concerning not
only because of what it means with
regard to what we should be doing about
alternative energy and climate change
and pollution in the country but it's
also concerning because it is yet
another one of these data points of
posit possible cognitive decline
experienced by Donald Trump take a look
at this video from the event and they
say the noise causes cancer you tell me
that one okay all right you know the
thing makes its own and of course it's
like a graveyard for birds if you love
birds you'd never want to walk under a
windmill cause it's a very sad sad right
like a cemetery of course of course this
just isn't true I mean wind turbine
noise does not cause cancer there are
issues with the noise there can be
psychological impacts which you could
maybe extrapolate into physical health
concerns but there's no evidence that
the wind turbine noise causes cancer and
as usual it's projection even though
Trump doesn't realize it remember that
Trump's been trying to revive the coal
industry which is an industry that does
cause cancer coal is not good for coal
miners coal burning coal is carcinogenic
greenhouse gas emissions huge air
pollution all of this stuff but it seems
that Trump just denies science and wants
to revive the coal industry anyway it's
sort of like a this is what I call the
natural news president or whatever
pseudoscience website you you
want to think about Trump has dabbled in
anti-vaxxer conspiracies he even tweeted
about vaccines causing autism
specifically remember this when he said
back in 2014
healthy young child goes to doctor gets
pumped with massive shot of many
vaccines doesn't feel good and changes
autism many such cases the Obama birther
conspiracy nonsense and now Donald Trump
says that wind turbine noise causes
cancer we have in the White House the
equivalent of the grandmother that's
constantly sharing fake news articles
that she saw on Facebook or the crazy
uncle who forwards without BC seeing
just that the 60 people that he knows
some whacked-out conspiracy that he
picked up on some conspiracy website and
I fought I saw funny interpretation of
the anti wind turbine stuff which is
that if you remember Trump was embroiled
in a controversy in Scotland because
wind turbines were built near Donald
Trump's Scottish Golf Course or resort
and it supposedly spoiled the view Trump
was furious and maybe this is how he's
taking it out on them by talking about
wind turbine noise causing cancer or
whatever I've truly never understood
that when the Cape Wind project was
being discussed here in Massachusetts
Pat and you had people on Cape Cod
saying I don't want to see that in my
backyard off of my dock a mile or so
away I think it's cool I like the idea
of looking out there and seeing look
it's renewable energy we're actually
doing something to try to stop harming
the planet I've never understood the
people that don't like the look of it I
say put put it put it offshore where I
can see it I love it yeah the arguments
against wind energy are just so bad like
this one in particular that they're
unsightly I don't think they're
unsightly at all I think they look very
cool another one they often go to is
that uh you know if it's not windy that
day then your TV's not going to work or
you're not gonna be able to heat up
something in the microwave like that's
just not how this stuff works and I
think Trump and these other Republicans
really have to get a better
understanding of it before they start
commenting on it yeah of course and you
know when we're talking about wind power
wind power would contribute to
broader electrical grid so that if it's
not blowing exactly at that time that
you need to run your microwave as Donald
Trump has said you have other sources of
electricity at that point in time the
arguments against wind power are really
really bad and I don't know if this is
evidence of Donald Trump's hyper
partisanship when it comes to
alternative energy or cognitive decline
that he would say something so
unbelievably out of place or some
combination of the two I don't know